Lamport's clock serves as the theoretical underpinning,
for achieving deterministic execution in distributed systems,
despite the fact that that there are
nondeterminism that are existing due to vagaries of
the network and due to drifts in the clocks, and so on. It's a
nice feeling that we can come up with. Conditions that need to be satisfied in
order to make sure that we can have deterministic executions and avoid anomalous
behaviors using Lamport's clock, both logical clocks.
Where it is sufficient, as well as
the physical clock conditions. In the next part of this lesson module. We
will discuss techniques for making the operating
system, communication software stack efficient for dealing
with network communication.